[Applause]
thank you so much
hi
as i was i'm anna
so
i am a ukrainian student at the
university of kiev
a few months ago on the 23rd of february
i had a quite usual routine
in the morning i had my classes and then
a wonderful walk with my friends
in the evening i was planning my next
day
i was wondering which kind of past i'm
gonna cook
i must have gone to my driving class
and i have plans to visit the gallery
but
the plan
it was never realized
and that day
has never happened
on the 25th
of february
at five in the morning
i've got a call from my mom
who was 500 kilometers away from me at
that moment
she said and are you okay cave is under
missile fire
she started crying because she didn't
know how enough i was to get away from
there
and
this is how
war started for me
that is how it started
for millions of ukrainians
from a terrible phone call
or message
that none of us expected
usually we're getting acquainted with
such terrible things as wars
through movies
or bugs
and never really consider them to be
part of our lives
that is how
it had been with me
through during the first semester of
this academic year our english teacher
presented us her unique course
named tv and queen class
the main idea of it was not just to
learn how to present the news or how to
work in front of the camera
it was rather to learn how to feel the
news
how to feel empathy towards what you
were talking about
and during that semester we were
covering war in syria
we watched quite a lot of times horrific
photo and video materials
we listened to heartbreaking stories and
later we went in the shoes of athenian
anchor and tried to deliver to the
viewer what had happened to syrian
people
and and i was really disturbed by the
situation happened there
but still
i had they saw that it was somewhere
away from me
in the past
and actually i still remember how we
were doing this i'm going to show you
we're standing like an imaginary camera
in front of us
we stay like a typical news anchor and
started
welcome back everyone i'm anna frautevir
and this is cnn drama newsroom
hundreds reported killed in syrian gas
attack
according to al jazeera syrian activists
claim that government has carried out a
poisonous gas attack in the rebel-held
suburbs of the capital damascus
hundreds of people including children
were dead
and then
at the end of this hunting story
was a sentence
the local coordination committees of
syria
calls it
a massacre
a massacre
for me as an english learner it was a
new advanced vocabulary word
with disturbing meaning
and if someone had told me back then
that this word would be applied to the
situation in my country
i would have never believed them
but as you know
it happened
months ago the president of the european
council charles michelle
used this word to describe what had
taken place in ukraine
and right now
everything has changed for me
everything
today i can walk peacefully here in
brussels like nothing is happening
because i don't see it
but it's not how it works
we are too interdependent and have
solidarity that doesn't let us forget
about anyone suffering anywhere in this
world
in syria
afghanistan
india
anywhere
and this solidarity is what i want to
talk about
this is a word which definition i don't
want to give
i very much doubt that there is at least
one dictionary that will fully describe
its versatility
but i'm sure i saw that word
i saw it in action
i'm also sure that you have seen it
that you have felt this solidarity
we all realize our interdependence
and that is how we are taught since
early childhood
we help each other
we work in groups during school years
we do teamwork
and this is not that we are not complete
as an individual
it is rather that together
we are stronger
the european tradition
laying behind the democratic success
is based on the simple premise
that we have staked in one another
and that what binds us together
is greater
than what drives us apart
imagine the strength and power of one
person
and what if there are hundreds thousands
of such people
there is nothing more unifying than
solidarity
you might not win war on your own as
well as you may not carry heavy bags
home
it's such different things but still
the same meaning
indeed true solidarity is proven during
that times
since that terrifying morning
millions of ukrainians
were needed to flee their country to
leave their home to leave their city
and when you need to leave the city
you're able to take only one single
suitcase with your whole life in it
so
imagine you need to pack your whole life
into this suitcase literally you have
one hour for it
what would you take
probably documents
maybe your laptop
school diploma your favorite t-shirt
book remember you have only one suitcase
your favorite cup pair of socks
this is not simple
actually i failed this challenge is when
i was evacuating with my cat in my left
hand
everything that was really important
necessary i left behind
and
this is the reality
ukrainians face
every single day
and
these days
are as dark as knight are
but then the solidarity of millions of
people around the globe
became our light
in these darkness
each ukrainian fills gratitude towards
the world community
that helps us to survive this war
and
i'm not even talking about political
issues
the solidarity of our people is more
than just resolutions and negotiations
it is visible through human kindness
and charity
i felt this when i was living kiev
the day i left
i found what real solidarity is
a stranger helped me to bring my
suitcase and gave me a live to a safer
place
i saw how customs officer was playing
with little refugee child
just to make her happy
i know how many europeans welcomed
ukrainians about their homes among them
my friends
and i know how many european
institutions do a great job like
european solidarity corpse
they provide humanitarian aid to
refugees that were forced to uproot
their lives and rebuild them across
borders
they help them they give them another
chance
to have a better life
and this is solidarity
i believe these situations might be a
good definition
by the way have you ever experienced
running to a bomb shelter
no
well i hope you never do
imagine you finish your walk day at the
office
you are tired it's late
you're having your dinner not so good
actually
and on top of that you're getting
bombarded
i can promise it's not as fun as it
sounds
to this
it's demoralizing
you put your cloth on you go downstairs
to the shelter
praying that you're survived this night
and actually one night when we were
hiding underground
there happened the guy from my
neighborhood playing guitar at 3am
just to cheer everybody up and later my
sister said happily oh we are so lucky
to have such a great lie here in the
bomb shelter let's start drawing and her
friend raise over with pencils and
notebook
and i was like wow at that moment
later i had stories from my friends
forced to move abroad but a really kind
barman somewhere in europe after
figuring out my friends were ukrainian
refugees
gave them coffee for free with hearts
drawn on the cups
a little later again i was watching
president zielinski address to the
european parliament
everyone applauded him and later
adopted a resolution supporting ukraine
here is this
free coffee with hearts
and here is the adoption of the
resolution in the european parliament
these things are on such different
levels
but they all have one matter underlying
guess which
absolutely it's it's solidarity
and you know the best policy is born of
a sense of community and unity
which is extremely useful when
addressing problems
and challenges
we must always remain kind true open and
understanding
this is exactly the spirit that modern
europe needs
countries must be as united as people of
those countries
this is a reliable guarantee of our
safety and well-being
the pandemic
worse global warming
all of this reminds us of how
interdependent we are
i believe this might be good opportunity
to restore our consensus through
cooperation solidarity and coordination
but the chances are limited
we must learn to prevent critical turns
not just to solve them
i don't know what a tragic history for
future generations to learn
let our descendants admire our victories
successes and achievements
so today
i'm voice of those
who were killed in ukrainian cities
who were lost forever
in the infinite silence
i know for sure that those were people
who loved their lives
and who loved freedom
and i know for sure
that they want us to be joint and
several now
joint
and several
which is never something abstract
unfortunately it is now not possible to
save those people
but we are capable of saving millions of
others we are capable of making lives of
many around the globe better
and this help
starts right here
in this room
in this building
on this street
solidarity starts with you helping your
neighbor and ends somewhere there in the
high office of the u.n
there is no small solidarity
there is always
one
let us never lose
of that essential truth
and i would like to end my story with
that the anchoring thing however with
slightly different highlight
so
welcome back everyone i'm anna forza
view and this is cnn drama newsroom
hundreds reported saved
from the war in ukraine
vulnerable position in syria
or denial of rights in afghanistan
these people were able to get a new
chance to get a better life
thanks to those who do care and provided
them with the necessary assistance
so if you're lucky enough
to get up in the morning without hearing
those sirens
and the permanent threat to your
security
be grateful
and help those
who doesn't have this option
we are all people
of this world thank you so much
[Applause]